[Music]
on this sunday night
out of control wildfires
the flames flaring up in bc in the past
three days we have had 73 new fires
start and the catastrophe that sent
thousands of californians running from
their homes
florida boards up and hunkers down for
issa is
how canada could be next in the storm's
path
mysterious trend what's happening with
kobe 19
in developing nations and if these walls
could talk
she wouldn't come in the tunnels for
anything one community's historic
hidden gem
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in bc where
firefighters are battling
dozens of wildfires most of them were
sparked over the past
48 hours as heather york's west explains
after a relatively slow start to the
fire season
lightning and high temperatures are now
fueling the threat
the green mountain fire on vancouver
island is currently burning out of
control
just one of many new fires sparked by
lightning across the province in recent
days
we did start with a very quiet fire
season compared to
the most recent seasons in the past
three days we have had 73 new fire
starts
while about half of those fires were
quickly contained more than 40 continued
to burn
the socal creek fire in the okanagan is
one of the largest right now
like green mountain it is also out of
control as soaring temperatures and
intense summer storms
help add fuel to the flames about 45
percent of wildfires across our country
are started by
lightning and when you see that dry
lightning so that's thunderstorms
rolling through without
a lot of precipitation to help with the
moisture in the soil
that is going to allow for perfect
conditions for wildfires to occur
the fire was basically right here the
fire season began early in b.c
this was the scene in the squamish
valley back in april
forecasts at the time called for a well
above average forest fire season across
much of western canada
but a rainy june turned things around
across the west the risk of wildfires
right now
is actually low it's only when you reach
parts of manitoba
and ontario that risk begins to rise but
as the last few days have
shown low risk or not fires can start at
any time
we're definitely not in the clear that
can't get complacent just because of
kind of what we've had
up until this point the risk is still
there
and with more heat and lightning
forecast for the next week
bc fire officials are bracing for more
busy days to come
heather urex west global news calgary
a wildfire in southern california has
forced more than 7 thousand people from
their homes
it began as two separate fires friday
evening between los angeles and palm
springs the flames
quickly joined together to form what is
now known as the apple fire
the fire has consumed more than 6 000
hectares of dry brush
and timber hundreds of firefighters are
trying to contain the out of control
flames
at least one home has been destroyed the
u.s weather service says
dangerously hot dry and windy conditions
are expected to continue
tropical storm issa east may not be the
mighty hurricane it once
was but it's still packing a punch as it
inches toward florida
thousands of people are without power
and the governor is warning residents to
stock up on a week's worth of essentials
water food and medicine as jennifer
johnson reports
canada is expected to be the storm's
next target
gusty winds and heavy rain move into
florida
as the state takes another hit in an
already difficult year
this one from issa east everyone should
be safely at
staying at home do not go out unless you
really need to
special shelters have been set up mainly
in hotels for cobot 19 patients
in case they have to evacuate you must
be honest when you come
in and the questions are asked please
answer them honestly because you're
not only continuing to jeopardize your
own physical health but you're now
jeopardizing
others emergency operations officials
hope the storm doesn't intensify
so many of their workers can monitor
things remotely
heaven forbid worst case scenario it's a
bit worse than you expected some things
go
the wrong way on you and then all of a
sudden your whole staff comes down and
has to be isolated for 14 days
that's kind of a horror show situation
for some floridians this is another blow
and an already terrible year
but for others the hurricane season
almost gives them a sense of normalcy
i have to admit this is probably the
calmest i've felt considering all the
other stuff that's going on in the
country
so in a weird way it's almost a sense of
relief
because it's somewhat normal for people
who live in south florida have to pay
attention to it
the rain is expected to create storm
surges up to 1.2 meters along most of
the eastern seaboard
the storm turned much more inland
which increases the threat of heavy rain
tornadoes
and flash flooding atlantic canada will
feel the effects too
easiest will start to lose some of its
tropical characteristics as it takes a
turn to the northeast this week
towards canada likely reaching close to
new brunswick by wednesday
where it could deliver some locally
heavy rain and some gusty winds
officials are asking people not to drive
in flooded waters
and if they have to shelter with other
people keep physically distancing
as this pandemic goes on any storm now
has the potential
for creating more than just weather
related hazards
jennifer johnson global news washington
a state of disaster has been declared in
australia's victorious state where covet
19 has come back with a vengeance
the state reported one of the highest
number of daily cases
671 and seven new deaths
the struggle to trace community
outbreaks has triggered some of the
harshest restrictions to date
an 8 pm curfew has been ordered in the
city of melbourne
and the only reason to be out of your
home between the hours of 8 pm and 5 a.m
is to get care to give care
or to go to and from work or be at work
police will be out in force and you will
be stopped and you will be asked
and you will need to demonstrate that
you are lawfully out
and that you are not breaching that
curfew
the restrictions will also require
residents to stay within five kilometers
of their homes for essential shopping or
exercise
melbourne was already under a six-week
lockdown officials say these new rules
will be in place for another six weeks
despite the pandemic some international
cruisers are back on the water and
already at least one ship
is reporting an outbreak of covet 19. 40
people mostly staff
from a norwegian luxury cruise liner
have tested positive
health officials expect that number to
rise the company is being criticized
because it let
almost 400 passengers disembark in
northern norway
before learning about the test results
that's triggering fears the virus could
spread further
into the community demonstrators in
israel
are accusing prime minister benjamin
netanyahu of mishandling
the coronavirus crisis and calling on
him to resign
thousands took to the streets outside
netanyahu's residence last night
it was reportedly the largest protest to
date calling for the embattled leader to
step down
netanyahu has been facing weeks of
nationwide protests over the state of
the economy
demonstrators say he's unfit to lead
while facing trial for corruption
charges
today netanyahu accused the media of
fueling the demonstrations
testing shortages are making it
difficult to understand the true toll of
covet 19
in developing countries many are
reporting lower death rates than richer
nations
adding to the mystery redmond shannon
looks at how demographics and data
collection may explain the different
curves
south africa reaching the grim landmark
of half a million cases is no surprise
but what is remarkable is the relative
low apparent
death rate there in canada more than
seven percent of confirmed covet 19
cases have died
that figure is even higher in many
western nations
but in south africa it's less than two
percent the figure almost is low in
places like nigeria and india
one issue is that poorer countries are
unable to test enough
unfortunately due to the global demand
particularly for test reagents
we haven't been able to meet our full
testing capacity
but low testing would suggest the
reporting of deaths
is vastly underestimated too seventy
percent of
deaths in india occur in the rural areas
and seventy percent
don't have any certification they don't
have a death certificate
we might have a hidden epidemic of
elderly people in rural areas dying from
covid
that are just missed because of the lack
of death certification
fewer airline links to poorer countries
may be helping them to react more
effectively
flattening the curve or maybe just
delaying it
i'm very concerned right now that we're
beginning to see an acceleration
of disease in africa another theory is
some sort of immunity in less developed
countries
a sort of hygiene hypothesis that
countries that have
worse general infectious disease burden
may perhaps
have some cross-immunity that makes them
less susceptible
to to covert 19. there's a general
consensus
younger populations in africa and asia
are keeping death rates lower
but without more testing it's difficult
to know
the only way for india to walk out of
this pandemic will be with much better
data
when accounting for all untested cases
worldwide
the actual death rate from covert 19 is
thought to be under
one percent but it could be years until
we really know
how much that varies and why redmond
shannon global news
london one of india's best known film
stars has recovered from culver 19.
bollywood's superstar amitabh bachchan
has returned home after spending three
weeks in hospital
the 77-year-old was admitted with his
actor's son who was still in hospital
button's granddaughter and
daughter-in-law ashwarya rai also
contracted the virus
they were discharged after a 10-day
hospitalization
posting the news on twitter the actor
praised the hospital's
excellent care you know when i was a kid
and got a hold of a nickel i thought i
was rich
and actor wilfred brimley has died he
was perhaps best known as the face of
quicker oaths and as a spokesperson for
diabetes education
brimley began his career as a stunt
rider working his way up to star and hit
movies including
cocoon the natural and the firm he
also made tv appearances with guest
spots on shows like seinfeld
and a starring role on the 80s drama
series our house
brimley was 85 years old
a deadly shark attack causes alarm along
the atlantic
coming up why scientists say canadian
swimmers don't have to worry
plus from liftoff to splashdown two
astronauts wrap up a landmark mission
south korea has been hammered by days of
torrential rain and more rain
is in the forecast the deluge triggered
deadly floods and landslides and left a
wake of destruction around seoul
officials say 360 people in the area are
now homeless
the death toll stands at six but that
could change
because several people are missing a
fatal shark attack off the coast of
maine has swimmers on edge
all along the eastern seaboard it
happened near a popular holiday spot
just off the mainland
and not all that far from canada
investigators confirm it was a great
white shark
recent sightings of great whites in
northern atlantic waters indicate
its population is on the rise but as
ross lord reports
scientists argue the vulnerable species
has been unfairly demonized
when a woman was attacked and killed
monday while swimming with her daughter
it was shocking even more so when
officials in the maine community of
harpswell
identified the attacker we were able to
recover a fragment
of a tooth and with that fragment
mr skomo was able to positively identify
this as a great white shark authorities
say 63-year-old julie demperio hollawock
was wearing a black wetsuit they suspect
the great white might have mistaken her
for seal
news that could have a ripple effect of
fear when you consider
the endangered great whites population
in the north atlantic seems to be
increasing
satellite tracking data indicates white
sharks are a more common and consistent
occurrence in canadian waters than
previously thought
scenarios include that tagging
technology is revealing the presence of
great whites that were already there
or that climate change is making
southern u.s waters too warm
causing the sharks to move north in the
summer months
if we have an occurrence of white sharks
in atlantic canada waters
then i think there is obviously an
increased chance of human shark
conflict there's no official estimate of
great white numbers
some scientists believe the population
has grown slightly in recent decades
the risk is very low this fisheries and
ocean scientists says
in the past 80 years there are only two
documented shark attacks in the north
atlantic
there's never been a fatal attack in
canada
when you consider the number of
beachgoers how much
we enjoy the ocean boats kayakers
really it's even rare to see the animals
let alone
interact with one which means beachgoers
might be better off watching out for
other threats
the majority of the risks for me and for
most of us out here it's it's other
surfers
so it's everybody's in the water it's
boards flying around that kind of stuff
secure on the knowledge the odds of
encountering a great white
are still a long shot ross lord global
news
lawrencetown beach nova scotia
two astronauts are back on earth ending
an historic two-month mission
with spacex 200 meters
we have brace for splashdown nasa's doug
hurley
and bob benkin successfully splashed
down off the coast of florida this
afternoon
they left the international space
station late last night
the landing wraps up an ambitious test
of the first manned
private spacecraft which launched in may
still ahead the triggers behind
america's gun sales surge
during the pandemic
you're watching global national
gun sales across the united states have
reached record highs
since the pandemic began in some states
shops selling these weapons are
considered an essential service
and even when other states tried to shut
them down they were still the internet
as reggie chichini reports a growing
number of buyers
are first-time gun owners as more
americans find themselves sinking under
the fear of the unknown
millions have sought safety in the palm
of their hands
it started with kovid and now it's
the riots pandemic panic has triggered a
rush on gun purchases since the
beginning of the year and data shows
it's not gun aficionados looking to arm
themselves
forty percent of gun sales were to first
time buyers
i've been wanting to do this for a while
but this is kind of like the tipping
point where
i need to protect myself roughly 14
million background checks were conducted
between march
and june june alone saw a 136 percent
increase from the previous year
these are the highest numbers in the
fbi's background check program
22 year history it might be something
that produces disorder
or perceived as disorder it might be the
black lives matter demonstrations
and counter demonstrations by the
beginning of the summer
gun permits in georgia tripled from 2019
and doubled in oklahoma new york
illinois and minnesota
sales of handguns are outpacing long
guns two to one
it's linked to self-protection it's it's
survival related
and while some criminologists say bursts
of sales are not generally followed by
increased gun violence
gun control advocates disagree gun
violence is a public health
epidemic buying a gun will not make you
safer now
nor in the future the economic situation
in the u.s has left millions of
americans out of work
studies show that increases the risk of
death by suicide amongst gun owners
by as much as 30 percent the damage that
you're going to cause and the
risk you're taking for yourself and your
family by this momentary decision could
last a long time
the current health crisis and national
protests are not the only reason for the
increase
the looming election has also sparked
fears among gun owners
that new gun controls could be on the
horizon a similar run on guns
happened just before the election of
barack obama the moral of the story is
use background checks to differentiate
the good guys from the bad guys and keep
guns away from the bad guys
at a time of unprecedented crisis more
americans are seeking safety
and comfort in their constitutionally
protected right
to bear arms reggie shakini global news
washington
up next the legacy of one of canada's
oldest churches
after it was lost to history
pilgrims in mecca walked seven laps
around the kaaba
the most sacred structure in islam as
they took part in the final ritual of
hajj known as tawef
the holy site usually sees millions from
around the world stand
shoulder to shoulder for this pilgrimage
the pandemic has forced it to scale down
with just a
select few living in saudi arabia
allowed to take part
while maintaining distance many
canadians are having to rejig
travel plans this summer fortunately
there's much to explore in our own
country
canada has over 1500 national historic
sites
one took mike armstrong off the beaten
path
it's a few minutes north of highway 401
between montreal and ottawa
on the ontario side of the border that's
where mike found the ruins
of one of the oldest churches in canada
these stones have stood for two
centuries the walls of what was
a hub not just for this hillside hamlet
but for the entire region
now they have a joke about the name of
this church if you're saying it right
then you're saying
it wrong it's spelled saint raphael but
it's pronounced
st raffle well when it was built
glengarry county was the eastern tip of
lower canada
scottish settlers started construction
in 1815
it was completed in 1821 we talked about
the seating there was a thought it would
hold a thousand
that's a lot of people yeah david
anderson is the archivist for the group
that's worked to conserve the site
he says when saint raufels was built
that old road out front was an important
thoroughfare
this was built to be right on the throat
of the great highway of the canadas
between toronto and montreal
stagecoaches ran down that street out
there dundas street
every day now there are theories about
what happened but no one knows for sure
on a warm night 50 years ago this month
someone
passing noticed a glow in an upper
window there was a fire in the roof
they called the fire department right
away eight generations of bernie
mccullough's family
had gone to st raffle this old building
with all them old timbers
there was nothing the fire departments
could do like they came from all over
they came from alexandria williamstown
martin town and all the departments came
but it's not going to win that fight
they're not going to win that it was
something that was that old what had
been so
important for so long 150 years
was reduced to rubble and the insurance
didn't come close to covering the loss
well in the 90s the community banded
together to protect the site
donations and fundraising paid to
stabilize it and in 1999 it was made a
national historic site
this church means so much to me for
dianna sturkenbaum that's meant
protecting the memories of the building
where she was baptized
delivered her speech as valedictorian
and where she was married
57 years ago this week i just love
when i come up here and someone starts
asking questions about the history of
the church and
i just love sharing it with others the
french one
with the anniversary of the fire coming
up it isn't the loss they'll be focusing
on
it'll be the history and the pride that
they were able to protect it
mike armstrong global news williamstown
ontario
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the old canva
sawmill
in wavenbc thank you for watching and i
hope to see you back here tomorrow
have a great night
you